we're flagging problematic posts for
Facebook that spread disinformation and
Facebook needs to move more quickly to
remove harmful
violative posts posts that will be
within their policies for removal often
remain up for days that's too long the
information spreads too quickly
and now we know that Facebook dutifully
took its orders from the White House
Congressman Jim Jordan and the Judiciary
Committee just released documents
showing how Facebook routinely caved to
the Biden administration's pressure to
censor Americans and in April 2021 email
from a Facebook employee to CEO Mark
Zuckerberg and CEO Cheryl Sandberg it
said we're facing continued pressure
from external stakeholders including the
Biden White House to remove posts that
same month Facebook's president for
Global Affairs told his team that Biden
covet advisor Andy slavitt was outraged
that they didn't remove a particular
post joining me now is house Judiciary
Committee chair Jim Jordan Congressman
what was that post
oh it was a meme it was one of these
like class action lawsuits that said you
know if you've been harmed by covet call
1-800 it was one of these kind of things
so they were even even censoring a meme
for goodness some humor
um and here's the kicker Laura they knew
it was wrong one of those Facebook
Executives said this is a significant
incursion into the boundaries of free
expression that is a fancy way of saying
this violates the First Amendment for
goodness sake but because they were that
White House was outraged because jinsaki
stood there at the podium what you just
played in the White House and demanded
this happened because the White House
was demanding it and they wanted to keep
their cozy relationship with the Biden
Administration they censored First
Amendment speech that's what this
clearly shows and frankly we got more
documents that were reviewing that I
think are going to show it even more so
what can be done about this as long as
Biden is in the white house I mean
presumably this is continuing in some
way shape or form
well I don't I hope it's not continuing
because we had that great Federal Court
decision on July 4th in the Western
District of Louisiana great decision so
I don't think it's going on now but we
got to make sure it doesn't go on in the
future it doesn't happen because we have
this amazing thing in this greatest
country ever called the First Amendment
so we're going to introduce but Rand
Paul and I have introduced legislation
senator Paul which would say if you're
in the government and you're doing what
was happening there you get fired you
don't get your pension benefits there
can be civil liability that you're
subject to you lose any security
clearance you may have we want real
penalties for people in the government
engaging what Professor Turley called
this censorship by surrogate this
coercion this pressure from government
on private companies to censor speech or
what Matt taibi by the way Laura Matt
taibi said what we're beginning to
uncover here is more significant than
the Twitter files and here's the he was
one of the primary authors of the
Twitter files and he's been attacked for
some of the things he's done to expose
this attack on the First Amendment so
um yeah we have that bill and and
stopping what what Mr Mr schellenberger
called the censorship industrial complex
now we're figuring out how this complex
worked and that's the first step into
stopping it
well I think they they probably know
pretty much what the Biden
Administration doesn't want out there so
the cat's kind of out of the bag you
don't even have to get an official Order
anymore you just there can be a wink and
a nod I mean I wouldn't be surprised
there's body language you know being
read here although we they want us to do
this
um Congressman on on this uh this issue
of of Hunter Biden I know you've been
obviously been all over this but we're
going to ask you the same question we
asked Senator Hawley how serious is this
that the doj was willing to give the
president's son a total free pass on
criminality potential criminality that
had nothing to do with the underlying
facts of his uh his crimes that he he
fled to
no it's it's hugely significant and I
want to your first guess all was on I
want to go to that October 7 2022
meeting seven people in that meeting
David Weiss and Gary shapley telling you
two different things there were five
other individuals in that meeting some
U.S attorneys other people on the
investigation I want to talk to those
people one of those individuals Mr
shapley's Boss and he's basically agreed
with what Mr shapley said because Mr
shapley put it in an email and sent it
to his boss but those are the key people
who want to talk to in addition to the
ones all talked about in your first
segment assistant U.S attorney Leslie
Wolfe other folks we need to speak to
and we're we're working on making that
happen as we speak
all right Congressman thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else